over the past few years one Chinese
company has thrived in the online fast
fashion industry reaching a valuation of
$66 billion in 2023 and controlling 40%
of the US market it's Shen shine I say
Shen it's Shen Shen is known for $2
t-shirts and $7 pants with prices even
lower than its
competitors Shen made its us debut in
2015 and the Brand's sales exploded
during the pandemic growing sixfold in 2
years The company generated an estimated
$23 billion in Revenue in 2022 and it's
filed to go public in the US Shen takes
fast fashion to a different level and
they're on top of every micr Trend but
there's a larger story behind shien's
low prices a congressional report found
that shien uses a tax exemption to cut
costs and the company released a report
that cited cases of involuntary labor in
its supply chain this is the economics
of shen
scrolling through Sheen's website can
feel endless we offer thousands of new
items per day but Sheen only initially
produces 100 to 200 units of each new
product Shen's designs originate with
Shen designers and with our xenx third
party designers as customers browse
those designs Shen has technology that
monitors users engagement activity when
a customer shows interest in an item by
hovering over it clicking on it or
adding it to their cart Sheen takes note
then it creates new designs Based on
data from popular items this way the
retailer can test how popular an item is
with its customers if it does well Sheen
starts producing more this differs from
traditional retail where orders can
often be placed in the 10,000 to 100,000
copies of a garment and can be placed
between 3 and 6 months in advance and
while it's fast at creating new designs
it's also quick to go through them a
Boston Consulting Group report found
that Sheen has an inventory turnover
rate of 4 40 days that same report found
that Shen is twice as fast as other
competitor retailers like H&M and Zara
the small batch model is a matter of
controlling the cost and controlling the
inventory wastage so that they won't
have a large number of clothes that are
sitting unsold in their warehouses in
China or in the US or anywhere else in
the world the company calls this an
OnDemand model and to support this on
demand model and lower prices Shen hires
thousands of smaller manufacturers ERS
it took the journal to film in one of
its third party supplier factories in
dongan our designers will identify an
item design it prepare a spec for it and
then they'll put it into our supplier
management system which will identify a
contract manufacturer that contract
manufacturer will procure the supplies
necessary to produce that garment from a
network of suppliers that Shen has
approved if a design is popular shien's
ordering platform can automatically
place another order with its platform
working in real time they're able to see
as demand for particular product is
either Waxing or Waning in the
marketplace so they can adjust their
operations accordingly and this
concentration of information allows our
suppliers to efficiently structure their
own business to be able to meet demand
at near Real Time by ordering in smaller
batches Sheen says it can reduce the
risk of excess unsold inventory it means
that we don't carry excess inventory
waste when we produce use garments that
saves around 30 to 40% in cost of goods
sold on the garments alone but while
less inventory waste in the factory May
lower prices for consumers environmental
activists say it might not lead to lower
waste levels overall critics are saying
that because Sheen's clothing is so
cheap um people are buying a lot of it
and because uh fashion conscious young
people may retire uh some of their Sheen
quicker than other more expensive
clothing that actually may cost
inventory wastage after the consumption
happened oh my goodness there's so
much a 2023 UBS report found that the
average US Sheen Shopper reported
spending $100 per month on women's
clothing that's about 60% more than the
average US female consumer and critics
argue that there's even more behind how
the brand is able to keep prices low
retailer xen is in hot water once again
Sheen has faced accusations of worker
abuse the brand has recently come under
Fire Sheen's ond demand business model
is now the only reason why its products
are so cheap it's also benefiting from
cheap labor in China Sheen has not been
fully transparent about its Supply
chains in 2022 Shen released the results
of its supplier audits but unlike some
other retailers Shen didn't disclose who
its suppliers were or where they were
located the audits reported some
incidents that involve what the company
called calls in voluntary labor but
didn't mention exactly how many or where
these incidents occurred the Wall Street
journal's calculations found that these
audits accounted for about 36% of
shien's contracted manufacturers the
company said in a statement to the Wall
Street Journal shien is committed to
providing a safe and fair work
environment for all our suppliers
employees we pay manufacturing suppliers
competitive rates so they can pay Fair
wages to their workers Shen says it's
committed about $70 million towards
improving supplier factory conditions
and training workers Congress is
investigating shien's labor practices
and whether the company sources cotton
from China's Shang region the US
government has accused Chinese
authorities of using forced Muslim
weager labor which Beijing denies some
us lawmakers have pushed Shen to be more
transparent about their supply chain in
a statement to wsj the company says it
has zero tolerance for forced labor does
not have contract manufacturers in Shin
Jang and doesn't Source cotton from
China fashion analysts say shien hasn't
provided evidence to back up these
statements including a list of its
suppliers which goes against industry
standard and in addition to its ond
demand model and low labor costs shien
also keeps prices low by taking
advantage of a US tax exemption which
allows low valued packages to enter the
US tariff free under the DI Minimus tax
rule shipments sent to individual buyers
in the US aren't subject to tariffs if
they're worth less than
$800 according to a report from the US
House of Representatives 30% of all
packages shipped to the United States
each day under the Dom Minimus rule are
from shien and its rival timu between
the two companies that adds up to
millions of packages Shen says that it
supports reforming the Dom Minimus
exemption meanwhile the valuation has
fallen the company's $100 billion
valuation in 2022 dropped by a third in
a fundraising round earlier this year
and teu which launched last September
overtook a larger share of of the US
market last June recently shien has
tried to improve its image through
social media amidst environmental and
labor criticisms but with limited
success Sheen brought a group of
influencers to tour factories in China
the tour didn't really help address a
lot of the criticisms that people have
about shien the company has also moved
its headquarters from nanzin China to
Singapore shien is also trying to
diversify its supply chain outside of
China with this move shien is also
adding new manufacturers in other
countries although the majority of
Shen's supply chain is still in China
the company promised to invest 150
million dollar to train 2,000 Brazilian
manufacturers over the next 3 years and
Shen has recently partnered with Forever
21 and acquired roughly onethird of the
fashion brands operator spark group
Sheen has in recent months been trying
to Pivot to a Marketplace modotto which
allows third-party sellers to sell
products directly to Consumers as genan
expands globally and is trying to
capture more of market share in in the
US and in other countries around the
world